A big news story breaks...
...so you head to your favorite online news source to read an article about what's going on.
There are thousands of online news sources...
...and some may feature unique information that complements the article by your favorite news source.
Google News scans numerous articles written about each story,...
...then surfaces those that are recent and relevant in story boxes that look like this.
Recently, we have improved that technology to surface a selection of additional articles...
...that will highlight diverse perspectives.
These articles will be labeled according to genre,...
...indicating that they are highly cited by other sources.
Include pertinent background information,...
...a produced local to the story,...
...feature foreign perspectives, or unique viewpoints.
You'll encounter these articles within expanded story boxes,...
...which also feature links to related sections,...
...options for sharing, and multimedia.
So find those stories that are important to you and start expanding.
The world's news, your news, Google News.